[Musique]
mais d'abord donc jusqu'où peut aller la
liberté de parole à quel moment une
opinion ou une formulation devient telle
une incitation à la discrimination
c'est cette question que doit trancher
le tribunal de paris depuis ce matin le
journaliste eric zemmour devenu l'un des
polémistes les plus célèbres du pays est
attaqué pour des propos sur les
trafiquants de drogue il y avait
beaucoup de monde à l'audience finistère
philippe maire
eric zemmour esquisse un sourire le
chroniqueur se veut confiant mais se
refuse à tout commentaire à la barre le
journaliste et combatif il maintient les
propos qu'il a tenus en mars dernier
lors d'un débat télévisé les gens
abandonner veulent vivre comme ça non
dès l'instant qu'on est contrôlé 17 fois
dans la journée ça modifie le caractère
si c'est arrivé
parce que la plupart des trafiquants
sont
poursuivis pour diffamation
il n'ya pourtant rien de condamnable aux
yeux d'eric zemmour la parole d'eric
zemmour n'a jamais été une parole
raciste
c'est une parole libre et les mureaux
dit appuyer ses arguments notamment sur
une étude sociologique de 2004
l'ensemble des minorités est sur
représentée en france à tous les niveaux
de la chaîne pénale en prime en prison
il y a dix fois plus de personnes
d'origine étrangère que d'origine
française autre soutien de poids
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
jean-pierre chevènement qui adresser
cette lettre au tribunal
sans doute monsieur zemmour at-il dans
le feu de la discussion utilisé une
formule excessivement brutale mais il
n'a hélas pas dit une chose
matériellement inexacte
pour les associations de lutte contre le
racisme
toutes ces affirmations ne recoupe
aucune réalité il n'existe aucune
statistique dans la mesure où les
statistiques ethniques sont absolument
interdite d'entrée toudic en droit
français
et que donc ce raisonnement ne se
fonderait sur strictement aucune vérité
scientifique donc seulement invérifiable
les associations dénoncent par ailleurs
l'analyse restrictive que fait eric
zemmour selon elle il ne prend pas en
compte tous les aspects de la question
il n'est pas dans un modèle où on
rechercherait a expliqué où on
chercherait à regarder quel est le
parcours des gens quelle est leur lieu
d'habitation quelle est leur
appartenance sociale mais a expliqué à
travers un élément à savoir l'origine
que ces gens seraient délinquants pour
eric zemmour comme pour les associations
antiracistes l'enjeu de ce procès est
important car il manie des notions
sensible la société a évolué et a changé
le seuil de tolérance n'est plus le même
et bien s'agissant des propos d'eric
zemmour c'est exactement la même chose
nous ne voulons pas évidemment jeté
l'anathème sur eric zemmour c'est pas ça
le sujet la question est de savoir
quelle est celle de la responsabilité
d'un meneur de débats ou d'un
chroniqueur qui est un leader d'opinion
n'at-il pas en même temps que des droits
des devoirs
le procès se tiendra jusqu'à vendredi
après midi eric zemmour encourt
théoriquement une peine d'amendé et
jusqu'à un an de prison
[Musique]